[Music]
thank you
on Christmas Day 2021 a massive rocket
was launched from French Guiana carrying
not only the largest Space Telescope
ever built but also the hopes and dreams
of thousands of scientists and Engineers
from 14 countries who made this moment
happen
[Applause]
two months and a million miles later the
James Webb Telescope arrived at its
destination
as its protective Sun Shields unfurled
as its golden mirrors locked into place
Decades of those dreams were realized
and exceeded
the James Webb Telescope has already
produced images of the universe that are
unprecedented in their clarity
these are gas clouds incubating young
stars as seen through the Hubble
telescope and here as seen through the
web telescope
this is a gas cloud surrounding a dying
Star as seen by Hubble and here as seen
by Webb
closer to home this is Neptune as seen
by Hubble and here by Webb revealing
gossamer Rings barely glimpsed in the
past
the web telescope has also captured the
turbulence accompanying the birth of a
star the spiral arms of a phantom Galaxy
the stunning dust Rings formed by
orbiting binary stars
as well as new images of our universe in
its infancy including what may well be
the first Stars created after the big
bang
data is already challenging our
understanding of how early galaxies
formed
and holds the promise of insights into
the nature of black holes dark matter
and dark energy
so today we are thrilled to discuss
these results with the very people who
are appearing through the lens of
humankind's most powerful tool for
revealing for us all a startling new
view of the cosmos
thank you
good afternoon
[Applause]
so good to see all of you I'm Brian
Green and as many of you may know I come
from the world of theoretical physics
where we use mathematics we use
equations to try to push the Frontiers
the boundary of understanding but of
course that mathematics it it doesn't
have any role in articulating and
understanding the universe until that
Math Makes contact with experiment with
with observations and of course leading
the way in the realm of observations is
indeed the device the James Webb Space
Telescope that you just saw a brief
summary of and so it is wonderful to
have a discussion of The Cutting Edge
results that are now coming from the
telescope we're going to organize the
discussion in three parts sort of like a
three-course meal in the in the first
part we're going to focus on the
insights into the early universe diverse
a formation of early galaxies cosmology
things of that sort will then switch
over to a second group of guests who
will focus more on the local
neighborhood what James Webb is
revealing regarding the solar system
planets asteroid comets
and finally in the third part we will
switch over to a focus on what we are
learning about planets beyond our solar
system so-called exoplanets and I think
the collective result of these
conversations will really give you a
sense of the true Wonder of discovery
that the James Webb Telescope has
already
spearheading and amazing things that are
going to be
in store okay so let's get going joining
us here in Brisbane is Carl glazebrook
who is distinguished professor of
astronomy at the center of astrophysics
and super Computing at swinburne
University of Technology in Melbourne he
is the current co-director of the James
Webb Australian data center Carl thanks
so much for being here
and joining us from Washington DC we
have Nobel Laureate John Mather who is
NASA's senior project scientist for the
James Webb Space Telescope he spent most
of the past three decades bringing the
web telescope to fruition welcome to you
both
[Music]
[Applause]
so John let's let's begin with you you
and I over the years have had many
conversations one in particular of
course stands out which was in December
of 2021 I believe it was December just
before the launch of the James Webb
Telescope and in that conversation with
a number of other scientists you were
describing you know um a certain degree
of confidence perhaps a little anxiety
about what might transpire over the next
year year and a half here we are now a
year and change later what do you think
how how has it done
it has worked beautifully we are so
thrilled with what it's doing and what
it's showing us and the observations are
perfect they're gorgeous the pictures
are beautiful in a way that we never
could have imagined and technically the
observatory is twice as good as we
thought it would be the pictures are
much sharper they we can see better than
we ever hoped we could ever do so
combination of surprises in the beauty
of surprises in the technical
performance and even the predicted life
of the observatory is now over 20 years
so it gives us time for people who are
just being born to come up and use the
telescope now that that is remarkable
and you actually I don't know if you
heard it but you got at least one person
applauding for the um for the 20-year
lifetime now when we've yes
[Applause]
so when we when we first spoke about
this I gather it was more of a of a
10-year Lifetime with the possibility of
longer based on how much fuel was used
to orient things once you got to the
Target location the so-called LaGrange
point so I gather that must have gone
incredibly well
yes it did the the launch vehicle got us
exactly where we wanted to go to use the
least possible amount of extra fuels for
adjusting the orbit and we thank the
Aryan Spice Company because they did it
beautifully
yeah so that that is that is really
wonderful we're going to talk about a a
number of topics but I'm just wondering
off the top of your head is there one
Insight that has come from the telescope
so far that really stands out for you
there really is we were surprised a lot
of astronomers are very surprised that
the galaxies seem to have grown hotter
and faster and bigger than we ever
imagined they would and we don't know
why if so that's the big observational
surprise you could say how come were we
wrong well I can't tell you yet but we
know from pictures that we made with the
Hubble Space Telescope we extrapolate to
what we think would happen farther back
in time than Hubble could see and with
some things wrong about that we don't
know so one possibility is that uh
galaxies are dusty dust grains absorb
Starlight and turn it into infrared so
the web telescope can pick up the
infrared that we might never have
noticed before so that's a possible
explanation for the puzzle that we've
been looking at but at any rate right
now we just have a puzzle which is not
understood
so Carl this actually leads right into
your sweet spot right this is an area
that you work on so can you just
elaborate some of them when John just
met them what what is the puzzle and and
where do we stand in trying to figure it
out yeah so it's been a very exciting
nine months I've been wanting for web
for 30 years and we were expecting to
discover the first galaxies because that
was his mission we weren't expecting to
discover them in the first week
literally these galaxies up here were
found within one week of receiving the
First Data from web and these are seen
just a few hundred million years after
the big bang and they're very bright and
they had eluded Hubble because they are
so high red shifted they're beyond what
humble could see but it's still quite
large and quite polite and very
extraordinary objects and and so when
you have a puzzle of this sort obviously
it requires confidence in a variety of
measurements you don't just want to see
the picture of the Galaxy you've got to
know when it Formed you want to say
something about its mass and and how do
you make those measurements and what
degree of confidence do you have in them
the web can do two things that you can
take images different wavelengths and
from the brightness of the light in
different colors you can deduce how far
away the Galaxy is and when you're
seeing it
and it can also take what's called
Spectra where the light is spread out
and analyzed in great detail and then
you can exactly now of course called The
Cosmic redshift the epoch which you'll
see in the galaxy and so maybe we can
just spend a moment on that because I
think it's pretty vital to everything
that's going on so John just quickly
when we're talking about redshift I
think many people are familiar with the
idea it's sort of the stretching of
light I think we have a little graphic
on it can you just take us through what
that is and why it's important to
understanding these observations
so the general idea that we have was
discovered almost a century ago the
universe is expanding which means the
distant objects are going away from us
at enormous speeds roughly proportional
to the distance
so if you divide the Distance by the
speed of motion you get the apparent age
of the universe so that was 1929 we
found that out and what this picture is
showing you is that when an object is
going away from us we receive the waves
less frequently than we would have if it
were just sitting still so that
stretches out the wavelengths and uh
that we now use this as a measure of how
rapidly the object is going away from us
so that's the reason that we have to
build an infrared telescope to see those
first galaxies
now Carl one question obviously that
comes to mind for anyone who's been
following the news
you noted how quickly those galaxies
were found and pretty quickly it was
also announced the redshift namely you
know how far away and how early in the
evolution of the universe we believe
that they formed that number was updated
also pretty quickly too and so why did
that happen why was there a change in
our understanding that happened so
rapidly yeah so the very first objects
had a theory discovered had very high
red shift and that was inferred from the
distribution of light and different
wavelengths but then the web telescope
have to be recalibrated when it was in
space and those calibrations changed and
they changed the balance of the lights
and that changed some of the redshift
answers and brought a few of them down
and so right now are we confident that
the redshifts that are being reported
are stable we're not going to likely
update those in a month or six months
this arranged some of them were really
comfortable some of them were not so
common for them and for some we actually
now have Spectra where we can just do
this dispersing the light and measure
the red shift exactly it is about three
or four now we've confirmed Spectra at
this redshift 12
Epoch which is about a few hundred
millions of years after the big bang so
we're now sure about those ones and
we're going to get very many more the
next few months and so the puzzle then
is that these galaxies formed really
early and they're really massive and
really bright and our standard
understanding of Galaxy formation would
not suggest that something that big that
bright could form that quickly is that
the issue yes so there's two things
there's firstly the Galaxy formation
models which predicted that galaxies
would be smaller and fainter and rarer
and then we had a empirical
extrapolation from hobble into its
earlier time which again suggested we
wouldn't find that many so both of those
seem to go wrong and so is that
something that people are upset about or
excited by
I personally I'm delighted it makes it
more interesting
um and make clear offense and
interesting physics happening early in
the universe and do you have any idea
what that might be
yes so somehow you have to form these
galaxies very quickly and build up mess
so Galax Galaxy formation uh is
dominated by the roll it's called cold
dark matter
galaxies can't form without cult dark
matter
so if I had allowed to speculate
outrageously I think that James Webb may
give us Clues into the nature of cold
dark matter in the early Universe
Suzanne the cold dark matter is what
forms the gravitational Center yes that
pulls in the surrounding material that
ultimately does become the Galaxy but
nobody knows what the dark matter is and
perhaps some quality unexpected quality
that might might explain things so
that's that's outrageous speculation of
mine but I've had a hunch and
and so if that's the case is that a
major rewrite yes you think so yes we
will see we'll be wrong right and um and
I'm just wondering behind that
conjecture is their deeper understanding
that you don't want to share yet for it
being too soon to let out because we're
very friendly here and um
we see a lot of puzzles in the early
universe so just like we've seen now
shows some quench galaxies we found with
Hubble uh they live they're living about
a billion years after the big bang but
these galaxies are really massive
they're about five times more massive
than the Milky Way is today remember the
Milky Way is being forming for 12
billion years yeah so this is like a
cosmic snapshot of a billion years after
the big bang these galaxies are super
massive and super old and the one in the
bottom right we found from a spectrum
with where it's like a million years old
already
so that points to something really crazy
happening in the early Universe in terms
of early star formation early Galaxy
information
and so John when you when you hear about
this I mean I I've noticed in previous
conversations with you that
um you always take the burden of
wondering if somehow the observations
are wrong and and I think that's a
laudable place to be because if you're
talking about major rewrites of
understanding you want to make sure that
the the data that you're basing it on is
accurate where do you stand in this
could it be that six months from now the
observations we realize aren't as
accurate as we thought or what what do
you think
I think the obvious relations will turn
out to be accurate but the
interpretation is tricky you see what we
showed you there on the picture are
little fuzzy dots and they barely
possible to see that they have a shape
and a size and a color and so we have to
make up our entire interpretation based
on a few little fuzzy dots with a
spectrum and a color and so that's a big
big jump and we do it with calculation
and Imagination and we could miss
something we could have met we could
fail to imagine what's really going on
out there and that's where our
interesting physics is going to come
from is we try to make our imagination
match the reality
a final question on this work in
progress
in order to really understand Galax
information obviously there's
fundamental physics involved as as Carl
you described but ultimately you got to
put this stuff into a powerful computer
and crank it through the code because
it's too complex for us maybe chat GPT
can do it but we can't do it you know
you know in our in our own minds and so
when you get to that level of simulation
aren't there a lot of wheels and bells
and things that you can tweak that might
take your Galaxy formation simulation
and allow it to match the data there is
and there isn't so Galax information is
as you say a complicated process you
have gas condensing Stars forming but
awesome
fundamental constraints so we can
simulate the behavior of Dark Matter
quite precisely so given the properties
of dark matter we can say how big these
dark matter Halos or globules dark
matter are early times and we know the
sort of what we call the baryon density
of the universe the number of atoms per
cubic Mega plastic so we had some basic
information about how many atoms there
are to form a galaxies so we're getting
sort of close to sort of violating from
those basic constraints in terms of how
rapidly you have to convert gas into
into galaxies yeah
um all right so we'll see where that
goes but it's certainly an exciting
prospect that when we understand is the
things may turn out differently from
what we thought another relevant topic
uh John that has certainly been
um an interesting motivation for certain
class of observations is called the
Hubble tension a discrepancy between the
expansion rate of the universe as
determined by two distinct approaches
can you just in a brief moment explain
what that tension refers to
yes uh well one model that's been used
very well is to take the hot and cold
spots what we call anisotropy in the
maps of the cosmic microwave background
radiation and get the statistics and
there's so many little Wiggles and bumps
in these curves that you can adjust a
model of the universe to match it very
precisely and we do that and we think we
know that the answer is and it we get
one number and then the we should be
able to match that to direct
measurements of the expansion rate of
galaxies running away from us and we get
a different answer and it's highly
statistically significant there's this
is a five Sigma or so which that means
there's almost very low chance that this
happened by certain random process so
something real is happening but we can't
tell yet if it's a mistake in our
observations a mistake in our
interpretation or just something nature
is surprising us with such as a new kind
of dark matter a new kind of dark energy
or something else that would be really
exciting just to just cover so if
there's a Nobel Prize in here that could
be one of them
as spoken by a Nobel Prize winner yes
absolutely good advice so so so uh so
just briefly a dark matter and dark
energy I think we're all familiar their
ingredients in the universe that we have
some confidence are there they don't
give off light but they do affect the
expansion rate of the universe and
therefore if we find something funny
with the expansion rate we might be
finding something funny about dark
matter and dark energy now Carl
famously there have been arguments about
the expansion rate of the universe going
all the way back to Hubble himself right
I mean and and so perhaps if someone
heard about this Hubble tension they
would say ah you know it's just one of
those things that you know ultimately
will will be worked out but this one
feels different because we're not
comparing two approaches that are
effectively the same but done by two
different groups to get the expansion
rate of the universe now we're getting
the expansion rate from early Universe
observations the cosmic microwave
background radiation that John mentioned
and observations of the later universe
and trying to interpolate between them
but the interpolation is not working so
where do you come down on that is this a
big deal is this extremely effective the
biggest problem in cosmology so you're
right what it is is a mismatch between
the expansion rate at Early times and
the expansion rate today
and today with the expansion is still
made by dark energy Early times of dark
matter we have a model to connect those
but the model doesn't quite match up
and when we measure it today we have a
dozen different ways we can measure that
and they all converge to a given answer
which is significantly disrepent what we
infer from the early universe so where
dang's web can help is actually
connecting those dots there are
techniques that change mode can apply
which can measure the expansion of
intermediate times and that may help us
solve this problem and do you have a
sense I mean John mentioned possibly a
new understanding of Dark Matter Dark
Energy would you go in that direction
too yeah I would okay so we just have to
wait and see where that that one goes
third topic is something you describe
this as the most important puzzle in
cosmology other people have described
the Holy Grail of observational
cosmology to see what's known as
population three galaxies or Stars which
would be the the first stars ever formed
after the big bang and correct me if I'm
wrong but just to give a relative sense
we believe that our son is a third
generation star sort of a grandchild of
the earliest stars have we seen the
first stars or evidence thereof there's
been some clients but the clients have
yet to be confirmed by more detailed
observations so let me tell you what
we're looking for so stars make heavy
elements so for example carbon oxygen
the stuff that makes up our bodies so in
the early Universe there's none of those
elements they were just hydrogen and
helium a bit of lithium and so stars
formed in the early University must call
it a pristine environment and that
changes their properties and makes them
more massive for example you have more
massive stars so the signature of this
population free is no heavy elements
extremely massive hot Stars so those are
the two key things to look for and but
the light you're seeing is coming from
stars and not from like black holes and
so there are observations suggest that
of at least one Galaxy but it's not yet
clear of those observations could be
explained by population free or by some
kind of unusual black hole
so that again is an open question but do
you anticipate that
we will with the James Webb be able to
finally conclusively yeah
I think we can we can go back and we
observe many things in more detail where
we find these signatures and we can look
at higher resolution get longer
exposures I think we'll resolve this in
the first few years first few years of
observation fantastic well you know
because we're on a sort of speed dating
approach to talking about the James Webb
today our time for this first section is
almost out but I do want to finish up
with one final question to both of you
start with you Carl in In Your Wildest
Dreams five years from now what will we
know that we don't know today from the
James Webb
had a first galaxies formed what's
driving the physics of that rapid early
formation is it some modification to
like the sort of the wheels of gas
information or is it something more
fundamental like dark dark matter or
dark energy and John for you I since you
started us off with this enticing
20-year time span perhaps I'll push you
20 years from now as the web is reaching
its final year of operation what do you
think the most stunning thing that you
hope that we will achieve with the
observation time
well there are two things where I think
we could get a big surprise one is the
early Universe we've been talking about
and the the origin of the giant black
holes you know almost every galaxy has a
giant black hole in the center and we
haven't really talked much about how
that happens uh but I think we could get
a big surprise in that area and of
course the other area where in 20 years
we could really learn something is
something about the exoplanets it's one
of the other very very difficult puzzles
that we're working on and we're working
very hard on them so something just
could turn up
and indeed we will be talking about
exoplanets in part three of speed dating
so with that please join me in thanking
our guests for part one Carl thank you
so much John thank you
[Applause]
all right so in in part two we are going
to move on to what the James Webb is
telling us about the physics and
astronomy and the more local environment
planets asteroids comets in our solar
system and to do that I am going to be
joined by a couple of wonderful guests
first here in Brisbane is Michelle
Bannister who is a New Zealand planetary
astronomer and science Communicator at
the University of Canterbury who among
other research will be using the web
telescope to gain insight into how
planets formed in our solar system
welcome Michelle thank you
and joining us from Washington DC is
Stephanie Milam who is Deputy project
scientist for the James Webb Space
Telescope at Nasa Stephanie studies
comets and asteroids to understand what
role they may play in the evolution of
planetary systems like our own welcome
Stephanie
thanks so much Robin
so again thank you both for being here
Michelle let's begin so you study what I
gather are called neptunian like objects
which are small icy objects that are far
out in the solar system can you tell us
why do you study them and how does the
web particularly help you in that
endeavor so these are the little
building blocks from the beginning of
our planetary system we think they form
around other stars as well the ones out
Beyond Neptune the ones transnept Union
objects these are the ones that are a
little more icy and competent in
composition so they're out Beyond where
water ice could still stay solid and so
they're Dusty they're icy they're
cousins of comets but they can tell us
about what that disc was like when it
formed and their little icy Hearts hold
the secrets of how that Evolution has
come through to the present day it warms
one's heart to hear about those icy
Hearts um so um about 80 you know 60 to
80 Kelvin above absolute zero it's nice
pretty warm by some standards
um
but are there particular members of that
class of astronomical bodies that you've
identified that you want to study you
just sort of look out and see what's
interesting so I have the pleasure of
being part of a team of collaborators
around the world and led to by a
colleague in the U.S who are looking at
about just over 60 of these small worlds
to see what the variation of surfaces is
like so what are we going to see in
terms of composition and more than 80
percent of those targets have now been
observed by day wst we're looking
forward to being able to release those
results soon energy particularly set up
to do this I mean what are the
wavelengths that you are looking in and
I presume they overlap strongly with
what the James Webb is sensitive to yeah
it's one of those things where if you
look in the wavelengths of light you see
with your eyes these objects look quite
red surfaces so they're they don't have
the Fingerprints of that composition
that is easily able to discern but when
you start getting into the wavelengths
that jwst can see and you'll start to
see those fingerprints of composition
and a lot of these molecules so they're
things like you might get in your
kitchen cleaning cupboard right it's
these kind of ammonia compounds or
methane or things that you know elements
in our atmosphere here that we breathe
like carbon monoxide that we exhale or
things like carbon dioxide and is that
surprising that you see those particular
molecules we think that cold enough
and if worlds they're on we present this
is what web is going to help us unlock
amazing so so Stephanie you know there's
a beautiful
image maybe we have it here and I think
we had in the original piece of Neptune
as viewed by Hubble and then as viewed
by the James Webb Space Telescope where
all of a sudden
you see these these Rings now when I was
a kid it was only it was only Saturn
that had rings so like what was your
reaction when you when you saw this
image
uh I was absolutely amazed I think
everyone in the world was amazed by this
image um it's absolutely one of my
favorites so far
um what is absolutely fascinating about
the capability of the James Webb Space
Telescope for objects in our own solar
system or even those Beyond is we are a
ring detection machine a lot of rings
around the planets or small bodies Even
in our solar system are made of dust and
ice and the wavelengths that James Webb
actually operates at is very tuned in to
seeing these rings as you can see in
this image some of these rings in this
Neptune image we haven't seen for 30
years not since the Voyager flyby so
it's absolutely fantastic that just in a
mere blink of an eye this telescope has
the capability to detect things that we
haven't seen without a spacecraft being
nearby for for decades
and so
the rings that we see here the rings
that we're more familiar with Saturn and
so forth are they more or less the same
or are there distinct signatures that
you learn something specific about what
you're looking at
um so that's a fantastic question some
of the Rings are the same and some of
them are very different we're getting
insight and clues into this almost every
single day now with with the James Webb
Space Telescope but also with other
observatories that we've used in the
past some of the Rings we can actually
see at Optical or visible wavelengths so
you can see a lot of the Rings of Saturn
as you said we could even see with you
know the stretch of an eye rings of
Jupiter but those are the rings that
tend to be a lot more icy a lot more
reflective so the ones that are more
Dusty are the ones that jwst is
revealing to us that we can't see with
other observatories so even in this
image of Jupiter you can already start
seeing those Rings starting to appear
and this was a fantastic capability and
demonstration for this Observatory you
know the James Webb Space telescopes
designed to detect to the farthest
galaxies in our universe and you know
planet that are
really really really beyond our solar
system and have a dynamic range and a
capability to look at something as as
bright as Jupiter and its rings in the
same image as a factor of ten thousand
and we are able to capture all the
Fantastic Glory of Jupiter and its
entire system the Rings small planet or
small moons as well as all the storms
the Aurora Etc and so do we know why
Rings form I mean are they a vital part
of planetary formation or do they just
happen in certain specific circumstances
rings are remnant of when the actual
Planet itself formed we sometimes that
dust is actually the material that made
that planetary body sometimes it's as
the the body is starting to form and it
has its own angular momentum some of the
moons themselves will will be colliding
and Destroy themselves and leave that
Dusty debris Trail around and some of
the Rings are actually formed by
processes within the moons themselves
for example Europa is an ocean World We
believe that there's
interior Ocean material that's being
spewed out into that system and we think
that some of the ice and gas from these
ocean worlds are actually contributing
and feeding some of the Rings around the
planets in our solar system
so Michelle there's also an example of
rings that were spotted but in a rather
unusual context correct me if I'm
mispronouncing the name but the shariqlo
is that is that the name yeah close
enough good uh so can you explain to us
what we are what we're seeing here so um
it's uh it's one of these little icy
worlds that orbits between the giant
planets so of the population out Beyond
Neptune there's a whole bunch of them
that have different different histories
they've encountered Neptune at different
times in their history and ended up on
different different orbits as a result
so this one this is a little transient
one it's bouncing around between the
giant planets and it'll do so for a
fraction of the lifetime of our solar
system maybe a few tens of millions of
years so it's a it's a brief interloper
for us and what is surprising yeah but
this is um we hadn't seen many rings on
worlds like this so how mayor a bigger
dwarf planet so um had been seen to have
a ring but shariklo it turns out there's
this beautiful set of two rings going
around this and so yeah this dwst image
here it's going very close to a star in
that image not quite in front of it so
the world itself which is you know not
much bigger than our the city we're in
um
that doesn't go in front of it but the
Rings do so you get this little drop out
of light just for a brief moment on the
Starlight coming behind as the measure
from the Spectrum presumably what
actually is in there uh that was a
different instrument that could make
that measurement but yeah you can see
that their their ice their crystalline
water ice and so is this an asteroid I
mean I mean what how do you classify
this object
objects as being kind of on a it's all
due to that formation right so what
these are made of this is a snapshot of
their formation history how things are
today is a they're all the product of
their past of where they formed at what
distance from the Sun so you know if we
say something's an asteroid we often
refer to that as being something that's
a lot more Rocky Rich so you look at the
surface and you might see
um the kind of minerals that you're used
to seeing if you walk into the Outback
but if you say something's more Comet
like or like these little worlds like
shariklo or trans other transcript Union
objects they're more icy Rich it's that
more kind of glaciers and Frozen
wastelands and exactly what those frozen
wastes made of can be very different to
what we see here on Earth now there was
a time when asteroids and comets were
really viewed as as two distinct
entities like so many things in the
world it's not a binary it's actually a
Continuum and then you have in members
yeah right so it's it's basically equity
and inclusion on a cosmic scale
absolutely yeah so so explain to us what
we're seeing here which gives a sense of
that continuum
yeah so this is giving you an idea of
what we know of the what I'd call a
dynamical populations around the solar
system so this is the small worlds as we
know them where they orbit around the
sun some of many of these are ones we've
found we still have millions more yet to
find Millions oh yeah we have a big new
Observatory called Reuben that's going
to provide more targets for jwst in the
future to go look at but yeah these are
telling you you've got the rocky
composition ones near the sun where it's
hotter just because the heat has sub you
know the liquid has evaporated off
effectively right yeah the Isis
supplement they can't they can't stick
around where it's too hot right
um and so so Stephanie you um
you've had some observation time on the
James Webb Telescope I believe
relatively recently right so what what
were you looking at
I was looking at this fantastic Comet
that was in the sky
um it reached its closest distance to
its sun in January it's a comic called
E3 from that was discovered by the zwiki
transit facility
um it was discovered just over a year
ago and it's been dubbed the green Comet
it was a fantastic uh bright Comet that
we could actually see if you were in a
nice dark area you could see it just a
little bit fainter than the Orion Nebula
so that gives you some perspective of
how bright this Comet was
um it's green in color a lot of comets
are actually green because of carbon
emission so whenever the ices are
sublimating from the comet when it goes
around the Sun a lot of carbon bearing
molecules are coming off of it and that
gives us this fantastic green color
so I had a program on the James Webb
Space Telescope to actually wait sit and
wait until we had a fantastic comment
that we actually wanted to look at and
when this one was discovered we had
predictions that it was going to do
something pretty fantastic and so we we
sat on our hands and had all of the
telescopes that we could possibly get
access to looking at this Comet to let
us know that it was actually going to be
something fantastic
we pulled the trigger in December and we
ended up observing it a few weeks ago
and we just got our data down and I can
tell you it's absolutely amazing and can
you share any insights on what you found
um
yes
um it's it's a beautiful comment um the
Spectra from James Webb Space Telescope
is is nothing less than than what you
would expect it is absolutely fantastic
we had a number of telescopes that also
from the ground that were observing the
comet at the exact same time so we've
been able to sort of cross-reference all
of our data from all telescopes all over
the world to to verify our findings that
we have with the James Webb Space
Telescope
the one thing that we can do though from
this Observatory that we can't do from
the ground is access a lot of the
molecules that are in our own Earth's
atmosphere so if we're wanting to see
something like carbon dioxide for
example we cannot actually observe that
from the ground so we actually have to
get above Earth's atmosphere in order to
to observe these kinds of molecules and
look for those fingerprints that
Michelle was telling us about and we
have a fantastic detection of carbon
dioxide in this Comet as well as some
other very fun new findings that I'm not
going to spill the beans on just yet
and and and so you know comets asteroids
part of the interest I mean they're
interesting in their own right but part
of the interest is we still are not
completely sure of how Earth got its
water and one of the possibilities could
be that was brought to Earth by say
comets where do we stand on that well
James Webb give us any insight into that
key question
we're already starting to get a lot of
interesting results from the James Webb
Space Telescope on water in small bodies
in general
um looking for things like crystalline
ice in the outer solar system of these
you know trans neptunian objects or
Kuiper Belt objects or even these these
things that are sort of in the Continuum
as as Michelle was beautifully
explaining
um there isn't seemingly a distinction
anymore between asteroids and comets
there's this diffuse sort of region
where we are finding more and more small
bodies and you know future surveys are
definitely going to help us find even
more but we're seeing that a lot of the
volatile material is actually a lot
closer into the solar system than we
originally thought
um the chances of a near-earth asteroid
hitting Earth are a lot higher than
something like a comet or a
trans-neptunian object for example so
understanding what the distribution of
water across the solar system is
something where a really striving for in
small body science in general and the
James Webb Space Telescope is the
machine that is going to tell us how
much water there is and the inner solar
system versus the outer solar system now
Michelle you know Stephanie Stephanie
I'm sorry just she made note of the fact
that the possibility of getting slammed
by an asteroid is perhaps you know even
higher than one might have thought
you've actually been involved in that
issue with the the dart Mission which
James Webb also was relevant to can you
just give a sense of that yeah so
so Stephanie was referring to the um the
probability of what the composition is
of um something that could potentially
be a danger to Earth but yeah so the
dart Mission
um which myself and many colleagues
around the world we had folks involved
on every single continent was amazing
um
what would what that mission was trying
to do is demonstrate the technology of
if you have an asteroid and at the
moment we know of no asteroids that pose
any Hazard To Earth but if we were to
find one that did
what would we do about it yeah and so it
was demonstrating let's take the moon of
an asteroid not the asteroid itself it's
Moon and take a little spacecraft to
about as big as what we're standing on
here on stage this kind of mat area and
let's boom A little nudge to that Moon
and then see how much we can move it
and so by watching that process happen
and seeing with the telescopes in space
and all around the world
um how much that asteroid moved we can
see the properties of that asteroid
because we didn't know there was a lot
we don't know about asteroids and one of
them is they're kind of like a rubble
pile you know like you see in a
construction yard but flying in
formation in space gravity is working
very differently so if you nudge that
how does it behave is it actually just
like a school of fish and you you know
you put a dolphin near it and it goes
yeah right it it's very different kind
of physics so we had to try to find out
what did you find with that mission we
found that you can move an asteroid so
yeah we can do this we have this
technology now and hopefully with future
generations of missions will be able to
build towards actually putting in place
a capability that if these future other
survey telescopes find something that is
a hazard we can do something about it I
mean but would you say at the moment you
feel more secure based on what you guys
accomplished and the understanding that
it's not just this big solid body of
rock but something that's more flexible
is that a good thing for us yeah it was
actually really good because it turned
out when the spacecraft hit the moon the
asteroid Moon material came off towards
the spacecraft as well and yeah this is
I love this one so this is the
um this is the artist impression that we
have I think we all Yep this is good
this is also some of the dart imagery
that we have from the spacecraft that's
the artist impression there of what it
would look like from something sitting
off and jwst actually imaged this I
think we have this one
do we have the infrared one so you could
say jwst actually was able to turn
around and look at this yeah it was that
a big deal it was watching in real time
so it was um Christina Thomas and the
team organized that so yeah this is from
a little camera that was watching that
was a little selfie Cam that the dart
spacecraft was released that was made by
the Italian collaborators and that
watched as Dart actually hit the moon
and jwst was watching um from uh from
back in its LaGrange Point as this
impact happened and you see this
beautiful spray of ejector come off of
the loose material coming back and that
was really important because the amount
of momentum transferred as these things
hit that's what tells us about how easy
it's going to be to move one of these in
the future and so we're not going to
need decades and Decades of lead time to
try and be able to move something we can
do it with less than a decade of lead
time for ones of this kind of size class
yeah no that that that's that's a huge
relief yeah
than you think they're going to be so
Stephanie you mentioned um Jupiter
before you've also been doing some work
on Jupiter understanding for instance
the red spot and its development so
forth can you take us through a little
bit of that
yeah so um the Jupiter system is
um a fantastic program that was accepted
um even before all of the the science
programs for the first year of the James
Webb Space Telescope
um it's a very large team of planetary
experts all over the world that are
working on the whole Jupiter system and
what's amazing about what we can do with
the James Webb Space Telescope is is
it's highly complementary to everything
that we've been doing with other
facilities both on the ground and in
Space
the long-term program that we can have
now with the James Webb Space Telescope
understanding how much longer of a
mission that we have due to our
fantastic launch gives us a timeline
that we can now extend the the Legacy
that the Hubble Space Telescope started
by looking at the Hubble by looking at
Jupiter and then following that and
seeing how things evolve over the next
20 years
one of the things that we know about
Jupiter is the Great Red Spot is
actually shrinking and we know this by
looking at it almost every year with the
Hubble Space Telescope and actually
measuring the size of that storm
the James Webb Space Telescope will now
follow in that Legacy not only
monitoring that storm to see how it
evolves in size but also in composition
so I'm sorry for interrupting but when
you when when people talk about a storm
can you you know
is it okay to use our experience with
storm on planet Earth is that what's
going on is it you know what's it like
to be in that storm
it's it's like a massive hurricane
it's a hurricane that's as big as the
United States we're actually studying
where in the atmosphere that giant storm
actually is with the James Webb Space
Telescope because at longer wavelengths
we actually see different areas of the
atmosphere
um so at wavelengths that we see with
our own eyes you're kind of seeing
things that are sort of at the
stratospheric level and as we go to
different wavelengths longer and longer
we can actually see various various
components of how things are interacting
across that atmosphere so clouds in the
upper atmosphere versus those that are a
bit further or deeper down and we're
also studying the composition of the
storm seeing how hot it is what is the
chemistry that's being stirred up by
this giant storm as it's going around
this massive planet and how is it
interacting with the other
atmospheric or other clouds or otherwise
that are in the in the general vicinity
of it so we're really getting some
really unique insight into what the
composition is how active the storm is
as far as you know its depth into the
planet but also how it's interacting
with its other with the other nearby
environment so there's a lot of
fantastic science coming out of this
program they say that it's shrinking
and and I guess jovians are celebrating
that the storm is starting to recede
finally but um do we have an
understanding of why weather patterns
here on Earth you know you have a storm
at last you know a couple days at most
why is it so stable even though it's
shrinking why is it hanging around for
for years and years
um it
typically due to just the Eric nature of
this giant planet
um we don't have oceans and
um and terrestrial you know impact of
that ocean and how it's interacting with
the atmospheric environment on Jupiter
so the storms tend to be a little bit
longer lived because they are they are
only this gaseous material that extends
extremely deep into the planetary
atmosphere
um down to we don't even know how far or
deep they actually go or and we don't
have access to penetrate that deep into
the atmosphere as well so understanding
how what the longevity is and what
drives them is something that's still a
pretty big mystery for us as far as
atmospheric science Even in our own
solar system let alone the Earth
well it's completely fascinating just a
couple of questions before our second
phase of this program draws to a close
um a question both you Stephanie you've
also been doing work on on the moons of
Jupiter I understand
I I know that there is you know
reluctance to share things until they're
fully accepted for publication and so
forth but can you give us a feel for
where that work is going
um absolutely so one of the programs
that we have for the first year of
science is studying these ocean worlds
across the solar system there are a
number of objects that we believe either
have
um these large bodies of Briny like
water that reside beneath a crusty
surface and that crust is usually
um icy in material
um and we know that there's these oceans
based on how how the planet's Dynamics
from nearby spacecraft how they orbit
how they interact with other bodies in
the general vicinity and so we've also
seen evidence of gas actually spewing
like a like a geyser out of the surface
of some of these ocean worlds
um one of them being a moon around
Saturn called Enceladus and then another
one there's been tentative detections of
these plumes around and around the Moon
called Europa so so one of the key
things we wanted to do with the James
Webb Space Telescope with its fantastic
sensitivity and wavelength coverage was
really see if we could actually
detect the plumes and also determine
what the composition of them are and so
we had a number of observations that
have occurred already the work is is
under peer review right now
unfortunately it's taking quite a while
to get through that process but we're
working on it we have some amazing
findings I will say that a number of
people have already accessed the data
from Europa I there's a lot of
interesting findings that were predicted
that have been confirmed and verified
now with the James Webb Space Telescope
um I'm not going to say too much more
without spilling the beans on that but
also for Enceladus we confirmed the
plumes of Enceladus that the Cassini
Mission actually detected and we have
some composition on what those plumes
actually are so this all feeds into you
know future missions to either of those
ocean worlds we're we're actually
launching a mission
um the European Space Agency is actually
launching a mission in a few weeks to go
to the Jupiter system it's a it's a
mission called juice so it's very
exciting times and the James Webb Space
telescopes only going to feed more and
more information into these bodies in
these worlds as we move forward in the
spacecraft approach those those systems
so Michelle final final question
you know we just heard from Stephanie
making reference to measurements of the
composition of the plumes Enceladus and
so forth
obviously I think the question that is
most prominent most people's mind is
will there be any evidence of life and
do you think James Webb is set up to be
able to for instance give insight into
that question and and where do you think
it's going to go
to make is going to build on a Heritage
of discoveries that came before and I
love that this telescope is for the
first time from you know an earth
proximate telescope to show us these
plumes right because we didn't know
about them until we sent our little
spacecraft the product of our hands and
minds and effort all the way to Saturn
and saw them up close
and so that is something where now we do
have that step in capability to start to
characterize it will the molecules that
they can you know pull out of these
Spectra these these Fingerprints of
composition is that going to be a
signature of life it's partly going to
depend what we mean by
what we think of as conclusive of life
we're going to keep seeing organic
molecules we keep going to see the the
building blocks of amino acids of things
that are um sometimes known as precursor
molecules for you know DNA and things
like that we're going to see these
molecules that are really necessary for
Life as we know it to take place
it's going to be really hard to go from
that through to is this the signature of
you know a little jellyfish a very small
one that has then gone shook into space
in a geyser and then we've happened to
see it right that's not where we're
getting to with this necessarily we're
seeing the pathway that's going to lead
us to be able to make these statements
as we start pulling together this
information so it's a it's a journey
right if this was easy we wouldn't be
doing it and and and and do are you
among those who view the discovery of
Life Beyond planet Earth to say Be The
Pinnacle of Discovery the thing that
will really change our sense of who we
are or do you think it's the kind of
thing it'll make headlines and then a
year later it'll be they found a
jellyfish in the bloom I mean a
jellyfish on a salad that's how cool
would that be but
I think it is going to like in the same
way every discovery about the universe
changes a little bit our conception of
who we are as people where we came from
how we relate to what our ancestors knew
of the world and where we ourselves now
live yeah it's going to change who we
are and how we think about ourselves but
it is going to do so in a way that we
maybe haven't thought of yet yeah and
you know it's that
we are at a point where we're seeing
ourselves in the universe in a new way
we are definitely at a point in history
where people are starting to view that
quite differently so I think we don't
know what it's going to be like to live
in a universe where we know there's life
I think the exciting thing is that we do
live in a solar system that's full of
these ocean worlds these kind of Worlds
with ice shells around them and oceans
under them these environments that can
be habitable so yeah I want to live in a
solar system where we think there's
things that can be like life on 5 or 10
or 15 worlds right and seeing that life
may have begun on planet Earth on the
ocean floor the oceans that we're
finding is pretending that possibility
in in a good way fascinating
conversation we need to move on to phase
three but please join me in thanking
Michelle and Stephanie thank you so much
foreign
so our our final section today will be
jumping off on this discussion about
planets asteroids comets in our vicinity
and talking about exoplanets and this is
a really remarkable chapter because look
if you think about it historically there
was a time of course when we thought the
Earth was the center of everything and
then the Sun and then we recognize the
sun is just an ordinary star in the
suburbs of an ordinary Galaxy of which
there are hundreds of billions of stars
let me learn about other galaxies and
each of them has hundreds of billions of
stars when we ask the question though
are we special in that our son has
planets that was a question that until
recently we really did not know the
answer to but now we do and as our
guests now will describe to us we
recognize that having planets is an
absolutely ubiquitous ordinary feature
of just about every Star so let's go
into a discussion of exoplanets our
first guest Jesse Christensen is NASA's
exoplanet archive task scientist Where
She searches for exoplanets and
determines which celestial object should
be included in NASA's exoplanet database
thank you so much for joining us Jesse
[Applause]
and finally we have Benjamin Pope who's
a lecturer at the University of
Queensland who focuses on developing and
applying new data science approaches to
detecting characterize exoplanets he's
among the handful of researchers here in
Australia with guaranteed observation
time this year on the James Webb Space
Telescope so welcome Ben welcome to you
both
so Jesse let's just
Jump Right In and just give people a
sense here so when was the first
exoplanet discovered and where do we
stand right now how many have we found
that's right so the first planet that we
found around something that wasn't our
sun was in 1992 so just over 30 years
ago and it was actually a really strange
Discovery people had been thinking about
exoplanets for a long time and trying to
think of ways to find them and building
instruments and doing surveys and
working really hard and then two radio
astronomers over here were looking at
this Pulsar which is like a very small
rapidly rotating neutron star and they
were like what's happening here and
eventually they worked out there were
planets going around this Pulsar so all
of this hard work to like set up for
decades to find planets it's these two
radio astronomers were like huh that's
strange so the first two planets we
found were actually around a completely
different kind of star a dying star at
the very end of its days
um it wasn't until three years later in
1995 that we found the first planet
around a normal star like the sun and
that was the the discovery that won the
Nobel Prize in 2019 the discovery of 51
Peg and so since then this has been an
Endeavor that has just turned up more
and more right that's right so if you
actually look at the number of planets
we know with time since 1992 it's rising
exponentially every year we're finding
more and more and more and that's uh
really because one of the things Brian
said is that we now know that planets
are everywhere most stars in the sky
have planets around them but it's really
the fact that our technology finally
caught up with our ideas we've been
thinking about this for so long looking
at these stars and wondering if they
have planets like our sun but it took
years for us to you know build ccds and
build spectrographs and get telescopes
in space so that we can finally actually
find them so last year we hit a major
Milestone of 5 000 confirmed Finance
outside our solar system now we're at
5312 as of today
5312. so so Ben Jessie made reference to
most stars having planets I made that
statement as well is that on firm
observational Foundation more or less so
uh you know um when I was a kid actually
the textbooks by the way you still look
like a kid to me but that's a different
issue 32 I'm 32. when I was a kid the
textbooks I had at school hadn't been
updated yet for the discovery of 51
pegasy and I was saying it's not clear
if there are planets outside of our
solar system and you know people used to
have theories that said this was rare
that this was the interaction of like
two stars passing by one another having
some kind of collision right and so
the really the big thing that changed
this was Kepler so um for the first sort
of decade of exoplanet studies being you
know a scientific discipline with
discoveries most of these planets that
were being found were often sort of
things like hot Jupiters we call them
which are you know mass of Jupiter but
much much closer to the Sun than any of
the giant planets in our solar system or
indeed any of the planets in our solar
system they'd be interior to the orbit
of mercury you know really really hot
environments things you know people
didn't really have theories for why
these should exist they were sort of
pathological that people pretty quickly
figured it out they actually form far
out and migrate in
so I think that's actually still in
dispute well you know there's people who
say they form in situ yeah yes they're
still viable institutions yeah anyway
we could we could get into that you know
anyway
um but uh
yeah so Kepler was this big revolution
where it was able to do a sort of a
server that wasn't biased just towards
finding these these short period high
mass things it was a little bit but it
was actually able to dig down to much
lower Mass things and go to long you
know long-ish periods of a few years
um find a lot of terrestrial planets and
I found that
planets are pretty ubiquitous so
um you know Jesse said there are 5 000
you know known explants I think she she
actually was being quite modest Jesse
discovered the five thousandth known
exoplanet last year is that true yeah
yeah it was actually the one that ticked
it over the uh Over The Line
[Applause]
but um you know uh there are many more
planets that we consider to have been
um validated statistically than you know
rock solid confirmed yeah and Jesse's
actually the one who sort of often makes
that call you know as head of the
archive they have to pass my bar yeah
but I just do wonder about one thing
yeah were you holding on to that planet
Discovery until it was
4997.99 then you announce I I'll
actually tell you it was a paper that
had 60 planets in it and I was actually
trying to avoid it being one of the
papers that crossed over 5000 because
NASA was super excited about this
Milestone and we're going to do all this
press and I was going to like I was like
it's gonna look like nepotism if I have
my own planner to be the ones that go
over and yeah so I really did try to
have it not work out that way but just
the order in which papers were accepted
and press came out it had we actually
put a bunch out together so I think we
put out 70 or 80 at the same time so
collectively we crossed the 5 000 Mark
together excellent and so of those I
mean what fraction seemed to be well
Earth-like is one measure but habitable
I guess is the more General
zeros
and then you said habitable and I said
two zeros and and so does what does that
suggest to you first of all what is the
definition of habitable for for this
type of exercise sure so for Kepler uh
which Ben talked about was a NASA
mission that ran for four years uh we
defined habitable as having a
temperature of the planet between 180
and 303 degrees Kelvin right so Earth is
273 degrees Kelvin so Earth is kind of
like in the middle sort of towards the
high end of that temperature range I
live in Southern California it sometimes
feels like we're at the very high end of
that habitable range
um but there's so many more factors that
go into habitability you know all of
these planets that we're finding we
actually know very little about them we
we can guess we can get their size we
can often measure their Mass with jwst
we're able to start looking at their
atmospheres which is super exciting but
often we know very little
um so we use temperature as a very broad
brush stroke to say this is a habitable
zone Planet it's in the right range for
what we say for liquid water to be on
the surface that's the habitable zone
where liquid water can be on the surface
but there's so many other things we
don't know about what you need for life
so for instance on Earth the fact that
we have tectonic activity the fact that
we have volcanoes and the continents are
moving on top of a liquid mantle that
might be really important for
habitability in terms of the molecules
that get put in the atmosphere and then
captured in the Rock getting circulated
we don't know how important tectonic
activity is for life so when we say
habitable and we're talking about
exoplanets often we're really just
talking about that very basic number
which is its temperature right but
there's so much more we don't know so
let's jump into to the web telescope
then what's the most exciting new
insight it's provided into exoplanets I
think
um so far all the the exoplanet
discoveries with James Webb have sort of
been um confirmation of its capabilities
we're seeing these amazing quality data
of you know um so the main way that
James Webb's able to measure the
composition of explanated atmospheres is
by the transmission spectroscopy method
right can you explain that just yeah
yeah and so you've got
um you know Kepler discovered all these
planets by looking for a dip in
brightness as they cross in front of the
star uh probably you're just saying a
planet
between us and the star just like the
transit of Venus a few years ago the
transit of mercury you know maybe some
of the people saw it here that was
actually you know an important thing in
Australian history as James Cook was
actually not exploring the South Pacific
to you know encounter and do a lot of
things in Australia but to actually
observe the transit of Venus from Tahiti
for for astronomy purposes you know
um and so this is a classic way of
detecting exoplanets but it also allows
us to find something out about them
because if you look for differences in
in how much light gets blocked by the
planet as a function of its color that
tells you the color of essentially all
the dawns and sunsets of the planet all
at once just in the same way that when
you look at a lunar eclipse you see the
Moon is lit up red By the Light filtered
through the Earth's atmosphere again we
get light filtered through this planet's
atmosphere and with sensitive enough
measurements you can measure the
composition of the atmosphere from those
details now the issue is sensitive
enough measurements Hubble Space
Telescope has done a bunch of
transmission spectroscopy of atmospheres
with claims of a lot of discoveries many
of these claims are pretty pretty solid
many of them are controversial the
quality of the Hubble data is sort of
just at the edge of where you're able to
make conclusive statements about
explanated atmospheres James Webb Just
Nails it it's you know it's getting a
really amazing quality data so far it's
mainly been looking at things where we
had a fairly solid understanding of what
we expected to see
what's going to happen over the next
couple of years is it going to start to
look at things where we don't know what
we expect to see you know if stars like
trappist-1 which I'm super excited to
see which is actually one of the closest
maybe systems of maybe habitable planets
I don't think they're habitable other
people other people disagree what do you
think Jesse
um
yeah yeah well so there's a there's a
really interesting phenomena talking
about how common planets are so rocky
planets like the Earth seem to be very
common around really small cool red
stars called M dwarfs so our sun is just
a boring yellow middle-aged g-star but
most of the stars in the galaxy 75 of
the 100 billion stars now Galaxy are M
dwarfs small cool red stars and they
seem like they're really good at making
rocky planets in their habitable zones
their habitable zones are much closer to
their Stars than than our habitable zone
is so it takes us 365 days to go around
our sun to be in our habitable zone
around an M dwarf it's more like two
weeks so you're very very close to the
star but that's a problem for M dwarfs
because they put out so much more of
their energy as high energy radiation
like X-rays and UV and that's bad for
life we live in Queensland you know SPF
and sunscreen was invented because UV is
bad for life so these planets they might
just be sterilized by their stars and
might have no app spheres so one of the
things that Ben's talking about is the
fact that we don't know whether these
rocky planets around em dwarfs have
atmospheres they might not in which case
they're not habitable by the sort of
life that we know which is a whole other
question completely sure um but that's
actually one of the things I'm most
excited about for jwst Jade whist
finally has the sensitivity to look at
these tiny planets around these really
dim stars and look to see if they have
atmospheres
so far so far we're not seeing much yet
which backs up Ben's point but I'm
optimistic because there's lots more to
look at
um and yeah I'm really excited to see if
these planets have atmospheres if
they're habitable the habitable real
estate in the Galaxy goes up by orders
of magnitude yeah now you have confirmed
the existence of photochemical reactions
through these kinds of observations as
well right so just give us a sense of
that sure um so uh when we're looking at
atmospheres uh often with the
sensitivity that we've had so far we're
just finding the the molecules that make
up most of the atmosphere so like here
on Earth we have nitrogen as most of the
atmosphere and then we have some oxygen
and then other Trace smaller amounts so
when we look at these atmospheres mostly
we're finding what is the thing that
makes up the bulk of this atmosphere is
it carbon dioxide is it methane is it
carbon monoxide so one of the very first
Spectra we got from jwst was of one of
these hot Jupiters so a gas giant heated
up to thousands of degrees because it's
right next to the star and there was
this mystery absorber we had such high
Precision that we could see the big
bumps we'd seen before with Hubble but
there were new little Wiggles and one of
them was a wiggle we'd never seen before
at a wavelength we'd never seen a wiggle
app before so this first papers came out
they were like cool new thing absorbing
at 3.9 microns we don't know what it is
yet so they went off and did a bunch of
work and it turns out it's silicon
dioxide sulfur dioxide sulfur dioxide
um and uh sulfur dioxide is a
photochemical that you know gets created
in the upper atmospheres of these
planets as the Starlight interacts with
the molecules at the top of the
atmosphere so for instance ozone in our
atmosphere it's a photochemical reaction
happens at the top of the atmosphere
again we have less ozone in Queensland
than other places
um but so this is evidence that we're
seeing photochemical reactions we're
able to see elements and molecules that
actually take up a quite small fraction
of the planet's atmosphere because of
the Precision from jwst and so at least
we're seeing
evidence for the basic ingredients of
life we're seeing evidence for the basic
processes that at least we know were
important to life on planet Earth as yet
we don't know as you're saying if other
details will somehow make things so
special here that life is rare
throughout the Universe but it's a
challenge it but it you know one feels
like it's going in the direction oh for
sure we're making progress you know
these are these are measurements and
questions we never had the ability to
answer or ask before and it's just you
know how much further down the road can
we get with jwst and and so Ben you you
have observing time coming up so what
are you going to focus upon not just
coming up
um it's actually just happened over the
last week oh is that right yeah it's
really exciting so um if people can say
this this is the prototype for an
instrument that's actually physically on
board James Webb it's the only
Australian Hardware on James Webb it's
the aperture masking instrument it's
actually designed by Peter teitel who if
you come into the exoplanets um panel
later is one of the speakers uh he's my
old boss can I just say one thing
straight out I'm sure it's deep and
important it doesn't look so impressive
so could you maybe give us um no it's
remarkable you know this is 19th century
technology yeah you're right you're
right
so this is just a tiny piece of metal
that blocks out everything but a certain
pattern of holes that are sort of
mathematically chosen to maximize the
quality of the image of the telescope at
really high resolutions right and so why
would we need to do this
um the issue is that exoplanets are very
very faint Stellar systems at Great
distances seem very very small you know
it's small because far away on the sky
and so you need to get really really
high resolution images and in particular
you know the James Webb um you know
mirror segments got the segmented mirror
they actually have these things called
tilt events where they actually
thermally jump as as the temperature
changes you know they actually get
dinged by micrometeorites this is
actually something that happened very
early in the mission and so there's all
these things that you want to be able to
correct for so you want to structure the
image mathematically in a way that makes
it really easy to do and so because we
we put Hardware on the telescope we get
rewarded in guaranteed time observations
right so Peter tells me that this cost
about 300 to have made in an expensive
alloy to go on the telescope but every
hour of James Webb time is worth about a
hundred grand of U.S taxpayer money and
we've got rewarded with a nearly a day
of James Webb time for contributing
actual Hardware so you know it's a
pretty good investment I think well done
you know and so
um we actually had uh on screen on one
of the slides I saw up up there um PDS
70 is this system uh yeah no I think
that one yeah beautiful so um P you know
the like planets just get names which
are catalog names this is the
protoplanetary disk survey object 70.
you know I apologize for the names
they're all rubbish it's it's very
prosaic but you know it's actually this
is one of the most exciting objects in
the entire sky this is a disc from which
planets are actively being born so you
know our solar system was formed out of
a disk of gas and dust I think Michelle
was talking about this earlier
um you know Michelle and her colleagues
and geologists on Earth can figure all
sorts of things out about that disc from
you know measuring the carbon you have
sort of the uranium dates of rocks and
you know other isotopic compositions and
stuff like that but what would actually
be really awesome is to see this process
happening in real time so that's what
we're looking at here this is actually
the only system I believe this is true
unless someone's published something
very recently the only system in which
we have images not merely of a
protoplanetary disk we've imaged a lot
of those but of a planet in that disc
pulling material from the disk which is
that dot in that image that dot is a is
a planet just like Jupiter it does the
great spider bright spot sort of
interior to the to the sort of level
which is which is sort of gas and dust
why is there a black circle in the
middle yeah well so this was taken with
a coronagraph uh which is designed to
block out Starlight and so the black
circle is is sort of dotted over where
the chronograph goes right that dot the
bright one is not merely a planet about
the mass of Jupiter but it's got a disc
around of it like Jupiter used to like a
scaled down version of star system
formation in which we believe moons like
Jupiter's Galilean moons are being
formed right now wow and so this is the
kind of quality image we have from the
ground and unfortunately I cannot show
you the image we got last week from
James Webb but I can assure you it's
much better and so um we're super super
excited this is
um you know the beginning of a long
journey this is for example you know
James Webb is great Hardware but it's
also partly a software Mission because
you know we launched it and yeah cool
it's you know it works really
beautifully it actually works you know
really really well it's actually
Gathering more light than we expected
and so some of the images are
Overexposed
this is a problem for us because we're
trying to get really really great detail
and so we actually observe three sources
this is the only one where the images
just came out straight away really good
because it's the faintest the other two
are going to have to do a lot of digital
processing but the data is there it's
just okay it'll be fine okay that said
my job now is I design algorithms for
analyzing Space Telescope data and so
we're going to get one that looks like
that but 100 times better and I promise
you too that also look like that but 100
times better but they're going to
require a lot more work and so
ultimately if you had a sequence of
those I mean you you really want to film
but the time scales are such that
looking at one image is going to be
tricky so if you find at different
points of their evolutionary development
at different locations then you'll piece
together the actual film by which the
planet is actually formed and we
actually hope to get a film of this one
so we can see it orbit and then we can
actually you know measure it and you
will be able to get that level of if we
do it a couple of times over a few years
yeah jwct gets that 20 years they were
talking about earlier yeah you'll be
able to see motion of the planet wow
so let me ask you can we book you for
the 20 20 year anniversary
um
um so
you know somewhat more of a fanciful
question we see you know these wonderful
developments in really understanding and
seeing Planet formation and how how
ubiquitous it is throughout the Universe
if we do encounter life and let's say we
encounter intelligent life
is there an opportunity do you think
that we will ever have real
communication with them will just be an
interesting abstract intellectual
understanding going back to the thing
that we discussed earlier or will this
really be integrated into some sort of
cosmic conversation sure I mean we can
extrapolate from times on Earth where
civilizations interacted with each other
for the first time at like different
levels of technological advancement
often it's not gone well
um Australia is one example
um and uh so you know we do these
forward-thinking experiments where we
think about what what would we be able
to see so for instance if it was simple
single-celled life it would change its
atmosphere the atmosphere would look
biological and you'd be like great
um this period of time that we're in
that humanity is in right now we've only
had radio communications for decades to
like a hundred years
um so if you think about the size of our
galaxy which is a hundred thousand light
years across and think of how far our
radio emissions have gotten in 100 years
which is 100 light years because that's
how fast radio travels we've we've
communicated with this tiny bubble of
the huge Galaxy
so one of the things we try to think
about is not how would we communicate
with ourselves right now you know one of
the obvious things to look for radio
waves coming from other places because
we are communicating with radio right
now but that's that's just going to be a
blip in human history that we're that
this is the way we communicate
um you know people are already starting
to look for lasers from other stars and
that kind of thing
um there's gonna we're gonna evolve and
we're gonna move forward so the question
is for instance if it was a sufficiently
advanced technology would we even
recognize it right like if we're looking
for radio waves and they're 100 million
years past radio as their predominant
way of communicating would we even know
what to look for
um so it's really hard to know so people
try all these different things you know
as soon as we get a new instrument like
database 2 we're like what would we be
able to see if there was life we can
look for Bio signatures we can look for
techno signatures which are signatures
of intelligent civilizations
um but it's a lot of guessing it's a lot
of trying to think in the future like
what what would we do in the future like
you know how the devices that we would
use to track more and more of the sun's
energy they would be visible in a
certain wavelength of light from a
certain distance like a Dyson Sphere
exactly exactly so you know we start to
when we whenever we do an infrared
survey of the sky people are looking for
Dyson spheres that will put out waste
heat from civilizations capturing all
the energy from their sons so it is
fanciful as you say but you know we have
to start somewhere so we're just
extrapolating from what we know now and
trying to think what could we see and
how could we see it and so we go looking
you know when you when you think about
the time skills that you mentioned time
scale for formation of life on the order
of billions of years civilizations again
on the order of billions of years once
live forms so the odds would be that if
we encountered an alien civilization
there'd be a billion year difference
between our state of development they
could be behind you know or weak could
be behind and so so do you ever sort of
imagine that you know the advanced alien
civilization is now
looking at the James Webb Telescope and
saying you know what they're doing okay
over there you know not yet you know
they're not but they're on a good I mean
at least like you know you talk about
the radio waves you know they're like
seeing
Trump
and the web telescope they're like you
know at least there's some people on
that planet you know that are maybe
worth our time the news about Trump
getting elected only just got past our
nearest stop thank God right like they
better know yet that's right right
because the two of you can't hold their
back right so so you know um you know in
20 years where do you think we'll be
with this science maybe just take us out
both of you with a thought on that
question maybe Ben about life in the
universe or what we will learn about the
study of exoplanets and will we get to
the point of being able to say something
truly about life I think we will I mean
I think
um the way I like to see James Webb at
the moment is
um you know say the early 20th century
people write science fiction novels
about the forests of Venus and the you
know the dinosaurs that lived there
about the civilizations of Mars on their
Dying World with canals and then in the
say the 50s 60s 70s we started to visit
these places and started to find out
that they weren't like that at all that
Venus this is so hot it rains lead and
you know in Mars there's no you know
water or air really enough for a
civilization and no trace of life in
either place
um
what we're at now is the cusp of that
Revolution but for exoplanets yeah where
you know um until maybe Circa 2010 we
had no idea observationally about what
exoplanet atmospheres and compositions
might be like we just knew that they
existed and then over the last decade
people are quite painstakingly put
together material from Hubble and from
other observatories to get some idea of
a few exoplanets you know at low signal
to noise at great effort James Webb is
going to start to do this systematically
and with high Precision for a lot of
exoplanets and so I'd like to think that
in maybe 10 20 years after Webb's had a
few more years to do this science we're
going to have quite a sophisticated
understanding of how planets are born
how they evolve and what sorts of
planets are there out there now web's
not going to have the sensitivity to
detect life per se but it might detect
you know what compositions of
atmospheres are there what are the
processes that shape these over over
sort of astronomical cosmological
geological time and the next
observatories that we have will actually
be able to say this particular planet
doesn't have life you know there's this
habitable worlds Observatory that NASA
is in Australia when's that supposed to
launch people 23 years from now yeah
convenient yeah and I think we're taking
a look at it right here yeah oh this is
yes this is one of the concepts that
went into this idea of a habitable
world's Observatory so after jwst
there's the Nancy Grace Roman Space
Telescope and then after that the big
thing that we're trying to build right
now is a telescope that would actually
be able to find earth-like planets
around stars like the sun uh jwst won't
get there it's a magnificent telescope
but it's not going to get to planets
like Earth around stars like the Sun but
habitable worlds Observatory will do it
we just have to that when you book me
back in 20 years
of habitable worlds all right you're on
yeah this is sort of a generational
thing right it's like Hubble was
launched four months before I was born
right and then we have waited until then
look I'm 32 you know we've waited until
really now for anything that exceeded
the capabilities of Hubble yeah it will
be as long again before we get anything
that exceeds the capabilities of James
Webb right it's like building Cathedrals
it's it's it's a huge generational task
yeah and uh and an amazing one and the
fact that this
incredibly complex sophisticated
instrument is doing not only what it was
specked out to do but doing even better
is really Testament to the the power of
human Ingenuity technology and
Imagination so rewarding for the
thousands of people who worked on it to
see the data come down absolutely so
thanks for spending time with us please
join me in thanking our guests thank you
really wonderful thanks thank you okay
thank you
[Music]